now can you put this cup over your head
no why because I haven't won it that's
right only those who win the cup can put
it over their head but you can sure give
it a hug thank you my assistant Mr Lou
cresser
oh so sweet that was long time Meet the
Press moderator Tim Russert with his son
Luke in the wake of Tim's death in 2008
Luke followed in his Father's Footsteps
to become an emmy-winning journalist at
NBC news but after eight years working
in news Luke went on a different path
and his new book has all the details on
that it's called look for me there
grieving my father finding myself and he
writes about his three-year Journey to
Find himself traveling to 67 countries
including Cambodia Senegal and Nepal
Luke Russert joins us now Luke thank you
so much for being here um it's a it's an
honor and a thrill and your EP told me
don't be a robot so I'll do my best
that's Shawna laughing in the distance
there uh the big cheese around here I
can't imagine you could possibly be a
robot uh the book is terrific I knew you
were good on TV I didn't know you were
such a good writer uh the title meet me
there or look for me there comes from a
moment between you and your father at a
baseball game you're a little boy and I
say this to my kids he says if if we get
separated he points to a place meet me
there and you and he says but of course
we'll never get separated and that was
one of those things where I was trying
to come up with a title and it was clear
that in the journey I was looking for
something searching for something but
then I also just remembered those words
of hey look for me there look for me
there and he did that so many times
whether it was after a rock concert or a
baseball game and there's still places
in in Washington DC where he would pick
me up from that I'll drive by and I'll
see and I tear up because I can see his
silhouette there just waiting for me the
details it's uh it's really heartwarming
but it's that reassuring note he hits as
a father saying but don't worry son you
know we'll never be separated and then
of course the tragedy of that separation
coming way too soon you're 22 years old
and suddenly you're speaking eulogy
what's that transition like for your
life and that journey to put you on
three Tony how about the audience in the
US oh my God John McCain yes the
president three weeks out of college uh
father passes away and I'm this sort of
happy go lucky free-spirited kid going
around Europe traveling with my mom at
the time and girlfriend at the time and
I get that call and immediately I go
into a mood of a motive I got a duty to
perform I have to honor dad I have to do
that to the best of my abilities so I
gave that eulogy which launched me out
like a rocket but in in doing that and
going into that church and looking out
and seeing John McCain Barack Obama
Ethel Kennedy Joe Biden all there
I realized okay I'm trying to hold on to
this flame and preserve it to the best
of my abilities and in doing that I
never really was looking Inward and
thinking hey 22 year old Luke your dad
your best friend he's gone yeah how are
you doing with that I didn't think about
it for years until I started traveling
and I got out of the news business and
that's something I regret I wish we
could go back to that young kid and say
Hey you really should have a moment to
yourself to try and at least understand
the ramifications of all that's occurred
and who knew Luke the pressure you were
facing going into the news business
you're following your rock star dad you
were doing a very good job but who knew
that you weren't so happy while you were
doing this and you decided I got to stop
back from this travel the world and find
myself and then after traveling it seems
like you still didn't find yourself I
was very private and I would put forward
a very uh sense of sort of jocular
bravado I internalized everything I
didn't want to let anyone know that I
wasn't doing okay at moments there was
one time I referenced in the capital
where I was so anxious that I I fell
over and I was able to hold myself up on
the wall and somebody saw it and they go
are you okay and I said oh well these
are just new dress shoes I I slipped
that wasn't true but I felt very
uncomfortable being vulnerable because
if I was vulnerable in some way then I
wasn't upholding my father's Legacy my
grandfather worked two jobs for 40 years
as a garbage man in a newspaper delivery
man my dad barely I think missed one two
days of work his entire career always
played through pain and and whatnot so I
sort of felt that sense of oh you have
to do this you have to do this there's
people who have so much worse off than
you yeah um but then came to the
realization is man my Dad loved me so
much he wouldn't want me to feel this
thing you know how I feel this way and
and go explore that a little bit and you
did and then but then you have a come to
Jesus meeting with your mom your mom
very respected journalist yeah Maureen
Orris after you've been traveling well
you've been to many countries and you
know
on this Quest and she says okay enough
yeah enough do something get a job start
working it's a mother it must have been
a very painful conversation it's hard
because I had sought this freedom and
for a long time for at least the first
year or so it was so welcome and I
really needed it I needed it to be away
from those types of responsibilities she
encouraged you and she encouraged it at
the beginning but as a mother has they
have that intuition and I think she can
sort of say that okay this very thing
that was so good for you is now hurting
you you're being untethered for too long
it's a tough thing to hear at any age
especially me in my 30s I I said you
know what Mom you're yeah you don't know
what you're talking about yeah I've got
to figure it out I'm going to figure it
out they'd say all the time because she
needed to travel right right I said
you're being hypocritical but it ended
up actually setting me on this path of
okay there is a clock now yeah and you
got to be conscientious to that you
can't do this forever and who are you
and it kind of forced me to try to
answer those difficult questions of who
are you independent of your parents in
your hometown like so many you grapple
with uh disappointing the people that
are around you yeah wrote about that and
I want people to really pay attention at
home because I believe they can identify
with this I feared failing in a job in
the life that chose me and I feared not
living up to the family name
do you still seek that approval and from
who is it your family is it friends is
it the industry is it yourself my father
used to say to me your name's Luke Saint
Luke first chapter 12 verse 48 to whom
much is given much is expected I
actually had that tattooed in my arm
that was something that for many years
haunted me because I go you've been
given all this privilege all these gifts
are you doing enough are you are you
honoring the Legacy are you honoring the
name and I felt the Deep sense of
inadequacy and it wasn't until I
traveled I measured myself up against
the world and I was able to have real
moments of self-reflection and
self-awareness that I realized that you
got to be good for yourself yeah and
nobody is going to be satisfied until
you yourself are satisfied with your own
abilities and your own psyche and when I
got to that place that was the place of
Peace So for me I put my heart and soul
into this book it has been something
that's been so rewarding and it felt
good to bleed out in the pay age a
little bit you really did look there's a
very poignant moment where you're you're
going to your dad's things 10 years
later boxes of his papers and you're
reading about your dad at your age the
things he had done what was said about
him at your age I can't it was a tough
moment we had all this handwriting we
had all these boxes in the attic and I
was supposed to go through them in 2008
and I had avoided it I had avoid it
because part of going through them meant
that he was really gone yeah and I come
back from traveling and I go up into
that attic and I have to sit on this
little stool my knees are near my ears
and I go through every single one and I
see his handwriting and so many times I
would just break down putting my hand
over that ink being oh god dad touched
this he's here he's here but I started
to see all the success that he had at a
young age and I could look Inward and be
like I oh my gosh 34 he was so much more
accomplished so much better off what am
I doing and it was hard to reconcile
that but it was important because it put
me on a path of okay
get going do something here are you
happy yeah I'm so happy and as we said
earlier you know you can't compare
yourself to a legend no right but I'm
doing okay yeah you're doing all right
and I think you still feel his presence
don't you all the time and uh that's one
of the most beautiful things you know
look for me there dad's right next to me
he's inside me he's he's always around
and I talk to him frequently yeah yeah I
said earlier you were separated but of
course you're not not in that way never
and and that's the bond between Fathers
and Sons are always there it's a
poignant book Luke Russell thank you
very much the book is look for me there
it is available wherever you buy your
books get a box of tissues we'll be
right back yes